recently House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
began impeachment proceedings against
President Trump related to his
conversations with Ukraine there's some
confusion as to the actual
constitutional process of impeachment
it's actually twofold like a trial
there's an accusation phase that is made
by the House of Representatives that's
actually what impeachment is and there's
a trial phase where the US Senate sits
as a jury hears the charges made against
the president and determines whether it
is worthy of removal a question I try to
address in my article is why have
Congress involved in that process at all
in fact if you look at Federalist 65
Alexander Hamilton gives reasons that
maybe Congress shouldn't be first he
noted that the impeachment process looks
a lot like a trial trials are usually
done by the judicial branch why then is
the legislature in this process at all
second he noted how partisan this can
become when Congress is the one
adjudicating this decision so then why
have it why is the Constitution allowing
Congress to conduct and follow
impeachment proceedings Hamilton says
it's because it's the best of all the
other options first generally
impeachment proceedings are about a
violation of the public trust
who better hamilton asks than the
american people's representatives to
make that determination if that trust
has been violated furthermore he also
says that the House and the Senate in
the way that they conduct this procedure
actually Accords well with their own
natures the house often a passionate
body is charged with accusing the
president of crimes the Senate which is
supposed to be cool and sedate and
reflective is charged with determining
whether an actual impeachable crime has
been committed
therefore we don't know what the result
of the process will be but we can trust
the Constitution and the way that it
sets out this process for our government
and for the American people